[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
— [іспанською] Готова?
— [іспанською] Так!
[іспанською] Один, два, три.
♪ [грає латиноамериканська музика] ♪
[Київ,
Наддніпрянщина]
♪ [грає латиноамериканська музика] ♪
Кубинський сон — це традиційний танець на Кубі,
скажімо так, він був батьком сальси.
[Анабель Чуприна
Танцівниця, викладачка танцю]
Дуже елегантно, максимально по-кубинськи.
Мені здається, що Латинська Америка
і все, що з нею пов'язано,
у людей асоціюється зі святом,
з легкістю, з кокетливістю...
Щось таке.
Ми зараз на Cuba Camp'і — це нова локація,
яку створили у 2020 році.
Хоча б, здавалося, де Куба, а де Україна...
І ми взагалі з татком тут трішки працюємо:
кожної п'ятниці ми танцюємо.
Ми розважаємо людей, створюємо настрій.
До речі, танцюємо під живу музику.
[російською] Я б сказав, що кожен кубинець
танцює вже з народження, ще в животі своєї мами.
[Рейнальдо Пауель
Засновник школи танців «Salsa Club»]
[російською] Чому? Тому що музика в нас грає
всюди на острові, майже 24 години на добу.
[російською] Я пам'ятаю, коли був студентом,
мені запропонували викладати брейк-данс.
[російською] Я написав мамі листа:
«Уявляєш, тут платять за те, що ти танцюєш!»
[російською] Ну це взагалі незрозуміло,
як можна: ти танцюєш, а тобі платять!
[російською] Вона [питає]: «Серйозно? Не може бути!»
«Але це робота, робота!»
[російською] Коли ми танцювали сальсу,
люди дивилися так: «Ого!»
[російською] Не було ще нікого, коли ми відкрилися.
[російською] І коли постало питання:
«А як буде називатися школа? Salsa Club!»,
[російською] то вирішили назвати просто
Salsa Club («Сальса-клуб»).
[російською] Потім отримали дзвінок із Харкова:
«Ми хочемо бути вашим філіалом».
[російською] З'явилися Salsa Club Kharkiv
і Salsa Club Kyiv.
[російською] Щойно в Одесі дізналися,
що в Харкові є Salsa Club Kharkiv,
[російською] то теж захотіли [заснувати] Salsa Club Odesa.
[російською] У 14 містах на сьогодні
[російською] вже розвивається франшиза
Salsa Club Ukraine — це така велика мережа.
[англійською] Під час пандемії Uber
просить відповісти на декілька запитань
[англійською] і зробити фото в масці.
Ось, що треба зробити...
[англійською] І зараз ми готові їхати!
[англійською] Я зараз чекаю на замовлення поїздки,
і я можу обрати її чи відмовитися від неї.
[англійською] Якщо це дуже далеко від мене,
я просто не приймаю запит.
[англійською] Знаєте, коли я був на Кубі,
то зовсім не слухав кубинську музику!
[Нельсон Караско
Музикант]
[англійською] Я був рокером з голови до п'ят, повністю.
[англійською] Але коли я емігрував,
я думаю, це трапляється з кожним...
[англійською] Коли ти емігруєш,
то маєш всередині почуття ностальгії...
[англійською] І ти хочеш повернути назад
ті моменти і спогади — все, що можеш пригадати.
[англійською] За деякий час я відкрив
заклад, де ми зараз є — Buena Vista («Буена-Віста»),
[англійською] який справді був першим
справжнім кубинським закладом у Києві.
[англійською] Більшість співробітників були кубинцями,
щоб люди почували себе, як на Кубі!
♪ [грає латиноамериканська музика] ♪
[російською] До України я приїхав ще за часів СРСР.
[російською] Між Кубою і Радянським Союзом
була домовленість про обмін студентами.
[російською] Коли ми приїхали сюди,
особливо коли вперше побачили сніг,
[російською] це було щось неймовірне!
[російською] Ми брали в руки сніг і їли його,
майже всі [потім] захворіли на ангіну.
[російською] Два тижні кубинці не могли
піти на заняття початкового рівня,
[російською] бо всі їли, пробували, що таке сніг.
[російською] У нас їжа переважно на основі рису.
[російською] Білий рис, темний рис,
[змішати] з темною квасолею і виходить темний рис.
[російською] У вас є гречка.
[російською] «О! Це схоже на темний рис!»
Пробували: «О! Нормально!»
І всі так [брали] гречку.
[російською] «А це що?»
«Риба, котлета, м'ясо»
[російською] «О, так-так!» І ось так куштували дві-три страви і більше нічого.
Холодець — ні!
— [російською] Ну що, готова?
— [російською] Так!
У мене взагалі був період, здається, з п'ятого класу,
коли я чомусь не приймала той факт,
що я чимось відрізняюсь від інших дітей.
Те, що мій татко — з іншої країни і взагалі, був такий період,
що я не cприймала своє справжнє ім'я — Анабель.
І мене у школі називали іншим іменем.
Мені чомусь хотілося бути, як усі,
я не хотіла відрізнятися від інших.
Але наприкінці старшої школи,
коли я вже потім почала вступати до університету,
інтерес до цих танців і цієї культури
почав з'являтися саме в цей період.
І з цього моменту я почала навчатися цьому більше,
аби потім навчати цьому людей.
♪ [танцюють під латиноамериканську музику] ♪
[англійською] Я походжу з комуністичної країни,
Україна також вийшла з комунізму.
[англійською] Отже ментальність і
реакція на деякі речі та проблеми у нас майже однакова.
[англійською] Тож деякі ситуації, коли американці кажуть:
«О боже, чому це відбувається?»,
[англійською] для мене не є нормою,
але я можу ці ситуації зрозуміти.
[англійською] Тому що в мене був цей досвід раніше, на Кубі.
[англійською] Я виїхав з Куби лише
через політичні причини. Жодних інших причин не було.
[англійською] Я не можу змиритися з місцевим режимом.
[англійською] Я не згоден з комуністичною системою.
[англійською] Якщо ви мене запитаєте,
чи хочу я зараз повернутися до Куби,
[англійською] скоріш за все я скажу: «Ні».
[англійською] Я б міг відвідати країну,
але, знаєте, за все треба платити.
[англійською] І Куба має заплатити ціну за 60 років комунізму.
[іспанською] Сьогодні Куба залишилася в 1990-х роках.
[російською] Коли я працював на Кубі,
найбільш оплачувана робота була у воєнних і медиків.
[російською] Я — старший лейтенант запасу
збройних сил Республіки Куба з радіорозвідки.
[російською] Моя зарплатня становила 20 євро на місяць.
[російською] На Кубі досі існує те, що у вас було
після Другої світової війни, — карткова система.
[російською] По ній дається чотири шматки хліба,
десять яєць на тиждень, риба, коли вона є в наявності.
[російською] Хоча ми живемо [на острові],
довкола нас море, і риба має бути кожен день просто так.
[російською] Але живемо дуже весело,
живемо танцюючи, живемо
[російською] приймаючи всі ці політичні проблеми, живемо далі.
[російською] Багато кубинців зараз можуть
за запрошенням виїжджати, куди хочуть.
[російською] Отримати посвідку на проживання, як я, наприклад.
[російською] «Я одружений».
«Будь ласка, оплати 240 євро, і все — паспорт».
Коли мені ще було два роки,
то на мій день народження тато, мама і я поїхали на Кубу.
І я нічого не пам'ятаю,
але принаймні бачила фотографії,
де я була на Кубі поряд з іншими дітками,
ми там святкували день народження.
Для мене було нормально,
що звідусіль вдома лунає музика.
В основному, вона була іспанською мовою,
але це зовсім мене не хвилювало.
Для мене було нормально те,
що татко з мамою розмовляють іспанською,
і я іноді знала якісь слова чи питала:
«А що це?», «А як так сказати?».
Мені, загалом, було цікаво.
Коли я вступила вже до університету
і в мене був предмет іспанська мова,
ооо, то тоді вже тато почав спеціально
розмовляти більше іспанською
і змушував мене більше говорити,
більше намагатися з рутинних справ сказати, запитати.
Якщо нам треба щось дуже таємниче сказати одне одному,
ми користуємося іспанською мовою.
[іспанською] Привіт! Ви теж будете героєм цього фільму.
— [іспанською] А як щодо пісні?
— [іспанською] «Візник».
[іспанською] Про це треба домовитися.
Ви проговорили це?
— [іспанською] Так. Той самий тон.
— [іспанською] Коротко і ясно.
[іспанською] Привіт! Все добре? Ти зірка вечора!
[англійською] Буена-Віста — це район у Гавані.
[англійською] У 1950-х роках там був відомий соціальний клуб, де збиралися люди.
[англійською] Він називався Buena Vista.
[англійською] Та будівля зараз зруйнована.
Тому ми його створили тут, чому б і ні?
[англійською] Ти ніби сієш зернятко, часточку себе тут, у Києві, і якимось чином це зернятко проростає, виростає дерево.
[англійською] І воно росте швидко і добре,
широко відкрите для багатьох людей.
[англійською] Тут багато латиноамериканців
з Еквадору та Перу.
[англійською] Buena Vista за ці роки вже має певну репутацію.
Це вже наче латиноамериканський центр у Києві.
♪ [грає жива латиноамериканська музика] ♪
[англійською] Ласкаво просимо до соціального клубу!
[англійською] Я нічого не знав про музику раніше.
Я роблю це, бо я це люблю.
[англійською] Я знаю тільки до-ре-мі і нічого більше.
[англійською] Інколи мені соромно,
коли я розмовляю з моїми музикантами,
[англійською] я не знаю музики, але знаю,
що і як я хочу.
[англійською] Мені соромно, коли я кажу їм, як робити,
[англійською] бо я не можу їм пояснити це музичною мовою,
але зрештою ми розуміємо одне одного.
[англійською] Знаєте, для кого я роблю музику?
Для себе. Знаєте, для кого співаю?
[англійською] Для себе! Я роблю це для самого себе.
[англійською] Якщо вам це подобається,
якщо люди це люблять, то мене це дуже тішить.
[англійською] Але це насамперед для мене!
[англійською] Напевно це те, що я передаю людям, і вони мене розуміють. Мені дуже радісно це робити!
[англійською] Інколи я закриваю очі і мене відносить кудись далеко, я відлітаю.
[англійською] І тоді я не в Києві, я ніде, розумієте?
Я повертаюсь додому.
♪ [грає жива латиноамериканська музика] ♪
[російською] Соціальні танці —
це великий вірус із позитивною енергетикою,
[російською] який з'являється всередині
конкретної української спільноти,
[російською] щоб народ почав розуміти одне одного,
став ближче одне до одного.
[російською] Цінували себе, як людей і як народ,
[російською] який  обов'язково повинен
мати свою мову, а не російську.
[російською] Наприклад, як я розмовляю, як мене навчили.
[російською] По ідеї, мене мали навчити
розмовляти українською,
[російською] щоб я з вами балакав українською,
я вважаю, що це правильно.
[російською] Я — кубинець, проживаю
постійно в Україні, але у мене українська сім'я:
[російською] українську дружину, українську дочку [маю],
і я себе вважаю українцем.
[російською] Коли була Помаранчева революція,
я там брав участь.
[російською] Коли була Революція гідності у 2013-2014 роках,
то я теж допомагав хлопцям — воду возив.
[російською] І я себе відчуваю реально українцем.
Я відчуваю себе 50 на 50:
і кубинкою, і українкою,
тому що по характеру, наприклад, важко сказати.
У мене дуже багато рис від мами, багато — від тата,
багато максимально типово українського,
і при тому це типове українське
схоже з типовим кубинським.
Україна — це фізичний дім, а Куба — це дім моєї душі,
такий — духовний, несправжній, нереальний.
♪ [грає жива латиноамериканська музика] ♪
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Оператори
Михайло Шелест, Олексій Панченко]
[Звукорежисерка
Анастасія Климова]
[Субтитрувальниця
Юлія Лєонтьєва]
[Коректорка
Леся Любченко]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки
Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]